14 pro vs 14 pro Max you just choose the
size that you like right wrong today I
will talk about all of the differences
that I found in the last two weeks using
these phones and which one I have to go
with this time around now the first most
obvious one is the comfort in the hands
I love the way the 14 pro feels the size
is just right even though I have large
hands the 14 pro still feels large and
then you have the whole fact of
reachability whereas with the 14 pro I
can reach most things on the screen and
the 14 pro Max things start to get a
little bit more difficult especially if
I'm trying to reach for things like
adjusting my brightness hitting next on
something trying to turn off my
Bluetooth or other settings now of
course we do have reachability so you
can swipe down and that helps out but in
general just pulling out my thumb trying
to hit stuff this is definitely a
two-handed device in general the 14 pro
just feels more solid you have a better
grip on it and it feels nicer in the
hand which is why last year I went with
the 13 Pro over the 13 Pro Max now the
year before that I did go with the 12
Pro Max and that is because it had a
better camera system and photos are very
important to me so I had to go with that
one but this year I found a lot more
differences in real world Usage Now the
next one some of you guys might expect
but the one after that I don't think you
will now for this one we have to talk
about the speakers the iPhone 14 pro Max
shocked us when we heard how amazing the
speakers were they were better in every
way compared to the 13 Pro Max but
getting to use the 14 pro I was slightly
disappointed and then I tested out side
by side well let's go ahead and take a
listen
someone around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the 14 pro Max is noticeably louder now
the sound quality is fairly similar I
would almost have to say that the 14 pro
might sound slightly better but it only
has about 90 percent of the volume as
the larger size and if you turn this
down by a little bit well then the sound
quality is identical and I love having
that extra Headroom and in the past when
he tested this both phones sounded the
same so that is a difference this year
with that if you're watching YouTube
videos or movies the 410 Pro also has a
larger screen but one thing I didn't
expect is the fact that a lot of ultra
wide videos are now in a letter box on
all four sides because Apple doesn't
want to cut into the island so the video
is smaller than previous years that
makes the 14 pro Max much more
advantageous and with that if you're
watching videos perfectly formatted for
the iPhone 13 and 12 series well on the
14 pro it does cut into the Dynamic
Island here and it cuts into the island
more so on the 14 pro compared to the 14
pro Max not a huge difference but it's
there because they do have a different
aspect ratio now the next thing I want
to talk about is cellular reception and
speed but before that whether or not
you're going to be upgrading to one of
these iPhone 14 Pros you're going to
want to keep your personal data
protected by using the premium Security
Suite from our sponsor Trend Micro which
offers complete protection for up to 10
of your devices including any iOS device
you have as well as Android's Max
Windows laptops and even Chromebooks and
when I say complete I mean it because it
includes all of the security products
including Maximus security which
protects against identity theft dark web
and data breaches malware viruses
ransomware phishing scams and other
threats as well as offering secure
online banking and shopping which of
course covers your mobile devices as
well you also get the built-in password
manager across all of your devices that
generates passwords and it comes with
keystroke encryption to protect from Key
logging malware even better it all comes
with their VPN proxy 1 Pro to protect
your web usage as well as turning public
hotspots into secure Wi-Fi connections
which is probably the biggest deal out
of the entire suite and finally you get
24 7 technical support and emergency
assistance included so check it out
using the link in the description below
and now let me tell you what I found as
far as cellular speeds and connectivity
you would expect that both phones would
be the same but they're not inside this
concrete building connected to 5G mid
band you see that the 14 pro Max gets a
much faster download speed and upload is
the same and both these phones are
tested one by one connected same network
same server held the same now switching
over to LTE both had the same bar shown
up and the performance was practically
identical now heading outside so we're
not in a concrete building the LTE
speeds once again were very similar
slightly faster on the 14 pro Max and
switching over to our 5G the download
speeds were slightly slower on the 14
pro but the upload was close to half the
speed and you guys can see that it
actually had one bar less reception I
know some people say hey those speeds
are slow I get way faster with my older
phone it all varies depending on your
network where you are congestion that's
why I test these in identical situations
same of a provider same server and it
just shows you the difference in
cellular reception based on the power
usage it has what Apple's allowing it to
do so if you want the best cellular
speeds you need the 14 pro Max now the
next thing I want to talk about is
display brightness now both of these
have 2 000 nit capable displays they're
beautiful outside combat that bright
light you can see it very easily and
that's amazing but with that I noticed
another difference and that comes down
to screen dimming now I did see my 14
pro Max dim outside in the hot sun after
it was running at that Peak brightness
and it wasn't a huge deal it dimmed just
a little bit brighter than the 13 Pro
Max series but with the 14 pro it
actually dims faster and more so and I
saw the same thing while playing games
and testing out some gaming benchmarks
that's just because the chassis is
smaller it can't dissipate that heat as
well it can't spread it out as well and
as far away so it does end up dimming
faster so if you're somebody that hates
that well the 14 pro Max definitely
helps now the same thing goes as I
mentioned with gaming since you have a
larger chassis well you're going to get
higher FPS for a longer amount of time
and less dimming as well because of
thermal performance and I ran our
thermal camera you guys could see how
the 14 pro is hotter and it's more
concentrated heat as well now with that
if you love gaming well the experience
on the 14 pro Max is much better you
have a much larger device your thumbs
cover up less of the screen you see your
enemies if you're playing like an FPS
shooter that I love easier overall it's
a much nicer experience and with that
you have a larger battery and that leads
me into the battery life section now at
this point I know that some battery life
issues have to be because of iOS and
different bugs but in general last year
I was able to use a 13 Pro because the
battery life had such a step up from the
12 Pro which I couldn't use a smaller
device that it lasted me a full day but
this year this device the 14 pro does
not now I know there's a lot of tests
online comparing battery life for
example Mr who's the boss he got about
two hours extra screen on time and real
world usage with the 14 pro Max and that
was always similarly the case but what
those tests don't show you is the
difference when you have the auto
brightness turned on when you're hitting
that 2000 they don't show you background
app usage with different apps pulling
your data while your screen is off
usually they're not testing out the
speakers being played either they don't
show you the always-on display being
used for example Phone Arena did a great
video and they compared it to the last
year series but they didn't test all of
that so the battery that didn't seem
that much worse or in fact it actually
did better in some cases but in the real
world my 14 pro Max performs similarly
or even slightly worse than my old 13
Pro with all the same usage Styles but
of course now we have always on display
the crazy bright display and I love
those features so this year the 14 pro
it will not last me a full day I have to
charge up around six o'clock whereas
with the 14 pro Max some days will last
me all day some days it doesn't so I am
literally forced to go with the 14 pro
Max yes even though I don't want to even
though I love the size of the 14 pro the
feel I would be okay with not having
that as loud as of the speakers
I would be okay with some of the
reception issues because I love the size
I cannot do it and when you add all
those other things in the loudest
speakers the display staying brighter
the larger screen for watching videos
and the speakers even though the cameras
are identical which matter a lot to me I
have to go with the 14 pro Max and every
time I pick up the 14 pro and put in my
hands I'm I just think man I should just
deal with the smaller phone because I
like it so much but I cannot so there
you guys go hopefully this video was
helpful in you knowing what the
differences are so if you're on the
fence one way or the other take this
into consideration click that Circle
above to subscribe to see more videos
like this one where we have real world
usage and real world differences not
just specs check out one of those great
videos are over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]